the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
8 video today I want to go over some of
the biggest unanswered questions and
theories from Game of Thrones this story
began 7 seasons ago but there is still
so much that we don't know with only six
episodes left you have to wonder is
there enough time to explain everything
also do we even want to know the answers
to everything because sometimes
speculating is more fun than actually
knowing the truth either way it should
be very interesting to see how they
decide to conclude this amazing story
now I did not put any of these questions
in any specific order but since there
are so many I would like to get started
right away so without further ado let's
begin number one who is Jack and agar he
is easily one of the most fascinating
and mysterious characters from Game of
Thrones I know this is a question that
fans have been asking for decades ever
since the first books were starting to
get released we first meet this
character back in the second season when
Arya Stark and ginjury were travelling
to the wall together what the other
recruits for the Nights Watch at that
time Jack and agar was a prisoner along
with two other men now what's
interesting is Jack and agar was
previously locked up in the black cells
which are located right under King's
Landing where Ned Stark was also held
captive we don't really know why Jack
and agar was in King's Landing but the
timing of his capture does create a lot
of speculation many people believe that
Ned Stark was also a faceless man but
not only that they also believe that he
could have traded faces with Jack and
agar so he could escape from King's
Landing could this be the reason why
Jack and Agoura immediately took
interest in Arya Stark the fact that he
was so interested in Arya Stark does
make many fans suspicious other people
believe that Jack and agar could
actually be Syrio Forel as you all know
we never did see Syrio Forel die and he
did disappear right around the same time
Jack and agar would have been locked up
in the black cells in King's Landing
now the speculation doesn't end here
because Jack and agar is also believed
to be Rhaegar Targaryen the truth is we
may never find out who this faceless man
is if he is anyone at all but I know
this is one question many fans would
love to have answered before the show
does end number two who is the night
king this is another one of the most
mysterious characters from Game of
Thrones the night king is the supreme
leader and the first of the White
Walkers not only is he the biggest
threat Westeros has ever faced but his
powers also seem to be growing with each
passing season this character was first
introduced in season four when he turned
one crashed her sons into a white Walker
ever since then the knight king's army
has been growing by the thousands this
was best put on display at Hart home
when we saw the night King resurrect
thousands of wildlings right before our
very own eyes that show of force left
many fans and even the characters within
the show absolutely speechless thanks to
the three-eyed Raven and brain stark
we finally saw how the night king was
created but no one knows who this man
actually was after that episode
originally aired many different theories
about the night King's true identity he
started to pop up all over the Internet
because of this many fans started to
believe that bran stark was actually the
night King now whether that is the case
or not is still anyone's guess
however if the night King is inspired by
the night's king from the books we may
already know which family he does come
from as we all know Game of Thrones is
based on the asanas and Fire novels
almost every single detail from the show
was lifted from the books so perhaps the
identity of the night king was as well
according to old nan not only does she
think the night's king was a stark but
she also believes his name was Brandon
Stark who the night King truly is is one
of the great mysteries of the show and
it's one of the answers I am
anticipating the most number three where
is Howland Reed as we all know Howland
Reed is the father of Meera and Jojen
Reed but he is also one of House Starks
most loyal bannermen the interesting
thing about this character is we have
actually never seen him in the current
story the only time we have seen Howland
Reed was during a flashback scene at the
Tower of joy but that was no order
mery seen that seem provided an answer
that fans were wanting to know for
decades and that of course was the
identity of Jon Snow's mother Ned Stark
died before he could ever reveal that
secret to Jon Snow
but Howland Reed on the other hand is
still alive and he might be one of the
only survivors from the Tower of joy who
can confirm bran Starks flashback but
the question is where is Helen Reed and
will he show up before the show ends we
know he was still alive when Ned Stark
was executed because Jojen said when his
father heard the news about Ned Stark's
death it was the first time he had ever
seen him cry george RR martin once said
that the only reason why Howland Reed
hasn't shown up in the current story yet
is because he knows too much information
but he also said that Howland Reed would
show up near the end of the story now we
can only hope that the same thing will
happen in the show as we all know Meera
Reed left Winterfell last season and she
said she was gonna go home to be with
her family but once Alan Reed finds out
what brain stark has seen in his
flashbacks and Meera tells him that the
White Walkers have returned that might
cause Howland Reed to get off his ass
and show up in Winterfell
number four will Arya Stark finish off
her hit list ever since the second
season Arya Stark has been keeping a
list of characters who she intended on
eventually killing there was roughly a
dozen different names on that list but
over time many of those characters have
died either by Arya Stark herself or
someone else the last time we heard Arya
Stark recite the names on the list we
only heard her say three names those
names were Walder Frey Cersei Lannister
and Gregor Clegane she also had
Melisandre and the Brotherhood on the
list for what they did again jury but
for whatever reason Arya no longer says
their names so if we're just gonna base
that on arias updated list the only two
characters that are still alive or
Cersei Lannister in Gregor Clegane
after Arya Stark killed Walder Frey and
the rest of his men she did start to
make her way to King's Landing to kill
Queen Cersei but once she found out John
and Songza had taken back Winterfell
she decided to go home instead as of
right now we have yet to see her reunite
with Jon Snow but we should be able to
see that happen at the beginning of the
final season once that does happen you
have to wonder what Arya Stark will do
next
we know she still has a bag of face
hiding under her bed and now she even
has a new Valyrian steel weapon thanks
to her brother Brian Stark even though
many fans believe jaime lannister will
kill Cersei and the Hound will kill his
brother could Arya Stark actually be the
one to get there and kill them first I
guess we shall see number five why did
Melisandre go to volantis
in my opinion Melisandre is another one
of those characters who's equally
fascinating in mysterious the last time
we saw her was when she had a
conversation with Varys right before she
left Dragonstone when they spoke
Melisandre said she would be heading to
volantis next but then she said
something very ominous it seems as if
Melisandre has already seen the future
in the flames not only has she seen her
own death but she also says she has seen
varus's death as well she also knows
that the night king is coming and she
has been preparing for that day ever
since she was introduced the last time
Melisandre spoke to Jon Snow
she told him she could help him defeat
the night king but she never did say how
now that she has brought Jon and
Daenerys together there seems to be only
one thing she has left to do and that
answer may lie in volantis where
Melisandre is heading next number six
what information is inside of Sam's
books when Sam and Gilly were traveling
to Old Town for Sam to become a maester
Sam said that he needed to learn more
about the White Walkers that way he can
help Jon Snow defeat them the only
problem was when Sam got to the Citadel
no one wanted to believe him
he did tell the other meissner's about
the White Walkers returning but that
basically fell on deaf ears
that left Samwell Tarly would no choice
but to leave the Citadel but before he
left he did take several books with him
some of the books were even taken from
the restricted area of the library since
he did this in the middle of the night
we weren't able to see what kind of
books he was taken but my guess is it
has something to do with the White
Walkers and/or the night king during the
season 7 finale we did see Sam and Gilly
arrive in Winterfell and shortly after
that Sam was able to help Bray and learn
more about Jon Snow's parentage but what
will they do next they had to have shown
Sam taking all of those books for a
reason but what information do they hold
will they be able to find out who the
night king is will they be able to find
out what the nigh king wants
or maybe they will find out how to
defeat the night king for good now that
John is on his way to Winterfell it's
only a matter of time before he and Sam
meet up again the night king should be
arriving shortly after that and by that
time we need to find out what is exactly
inside of those books number seven how
will everyone react to the news about
Jon Snow as we all know Jon Snow is the
legitimate son of Rhaegar Targaryen and
Lyanna Stark which does mean that John
has the rightful claim to the Iron
Throne the bad news is this could mean
trouble for Jon Snow not only are the
Targaryen hated in the north but
Daenerys also believes that she has the
rightful claim to the throne now we all
know that Daenerys obviously cares about
John but this is something that she has
wanted for so long and she has already
sacrificed so much in order to claim her
spot as the rightful queen could she
begin to see Jon as someone else she
needs to get out of her way for her to
claim what she thinks is rightfully hers
then on the other hand you have John's
Bannerman in his very own family when
John was getting ready to leave
Winterfell degree within hours for the
first time Sansa and the northern Lords
made it very clear how they felt about
the Targaryen 's so when and if that
information gets revealed next season
John could potentially face backlash
from almost everyone that is close to
him this should make for some very
interesting scenes in Winterfell
number eight who is the prince or
princess that was promised
according to Melisandre the prince was
prophesized thousands of years ago
Melisandre states that when the red star
bleeds and the darkness gathers azor
Ahai shall be born again amid smoke and
salt now it's unclear whether or not as
aura high in the prince who was promised
or the same figure but it does appear to
be that way
over the course of the story there had
been several candidates who were
believed to fulfill the prophecy during
Melisandre introduction on the beats of
Dragonstone she does claim that Stannis
Baratheon is the prince that was
promised but once he dies Melisandre
begins to set her sights on Jon Snow
however thanks to missandei we later
find out that this prophecy could be
fulfilled by a woman that led many fans
to believing it could be Daenerys
Targaryen this is a question that fans
have been wanting answered for decades
now whether it actually comes to
fruition
artist Oh anyone's gasps well maybe that
has something to do with Melisandre
heading to volantis and if so we will
find out next season number nine what
does the knight King once although the
knight King wasn't introduced until much
later this is another thing that fans
have been wanting to know ever since the
pilot episode of Game of Thrones the
White Walkers were introduced in the
opening scene of the opening episode yet
we still aren't exactly sure what they
want there are a lot of unanswered
questions when it comes to the knight
King and the White Walkers like who is
the knight King why did he return now
and ultimately what does he want now
that the battle for the dawn has on the
horizon it's more important now than
ever that we try to understand
everything we can about the White
Walkers and how to defeat them some
would say that this answer is rather
simple the knight king was created by
the children of the forest as a weapon
to kill mankind but is that still the
only thing that he seeks I don't think
so and there are other theories that say
the knight king is coming to claim a
knight's queen or he's coming after
gillies son it would make things so much
easier if someone was able to
communicate what the knight King to find
out exactly what he wants but
unfortunately we have never heard him
speak at the end of the day in order for
us to understand the knight King's
motives bran stark may have to go inside
of the weirwood net one more time to
find those answers number 10 who will
sit on the Iron Throne ever since the
start of the series the Iron Throne has
stood in as the ultimate symbol of power
many different characters have bled and
many different characters have died over
who they think should claim that seat
and gain the Seven Kingdoms as of right
now Cersei Lannister currently occupies
the Iron Throne
however she might not be the one sitting
there when the show comes to an end
after all Daenerys Targaryen has
traveled a great distance to come and
claim what she believes to be rightfully
hers but she isn't the only Targaryen
who has a claim according to brain stark
since Jon Snow is the legitimate son of
Rhaegar Targaryen and Lyanna stark he
says he has the rightful claim to the
throne but will Jon Snow even want it
one thing is for sure neither John nor
Daenerys won Cersei Lannister to remain
as the queen of the Seven Kingdoms but
they aren't the only ones who may have
their eyes on the ultimate prize as we
all know the night King is currently
on his way south with an army of his own
and until we find out what he actually
wants we can't count him out as someone
who may want to claim the throne for
himself now some would say that Daenerys
may have the best chance to take the
throne because not only does she want it
the most but she also has two very large
dragons that will help her take it
however you cannot ignore the vision
Daenerys had back in the second season
when Daenerys Targaryen walked into the
Great Hall we could see there was damage
done to the ceiling and there was snow
falling all over the room and the Iron
Throne some fans have thought that this
may be ash
but the director of the episode did
confirm that that was indeed snow
falling on the throne Daenerys was never
able to claim the throne in that vision
she does reach out to touch it but when
she hears her dragon she turns around
and she leaves before she ever does that
could be a good indication that Daenerys
will never sit on the Iron Throne and if
that's the case who will the snow
falling on the Iron Throne is obvious
symbolism for Jon Snow having the
rightful claim but does that mean he
will take the throne for himself not
necessarily but I would like to think
that the chances of Cersei keeping the
Iron Throne for herself are very slim
some of the unanswered questions I
brought up in this video may never get
answered before the show does end but
when it comes to the Iron Throne we will
absolutely find out if Cersei is able to
remain as the queen of the Seven
Kingdoms or not let me know what you
these questions you think will be
answered by the end of the a season I'm
interested in seeing what some of you
have to say anyways I want to thank
everyone for watching the video I
appreciate that as always and I also
want to thank all of you who support the
channel on patreon I hope everyone has a
great day I will see you again very soon